bremerhaven is one of Europe's largest
ports and the center of the offshore
wind power industry the city has
invested hundreds of millions of euros
and attracted major companies four
thousand new jobs were created in the
past few years alone now orders are
stagnating employees are being put on
part-time work at the power blades
factory large roaches on a floor are
just here for repair and maintenance the
250 employees would rather be making new
rotors but it looks as if the hall will
remain empty in months to come as well
burning yawn I'm a few years ago we all
thought wind energy was the future and
we didn't have to worry about the future
now the industry is a shambles nobody
knows what's going to happen you for me
I'm hoping my boys knew he was gone yeah
we're all worried about losing our jobs
that all we've built up here is for
nothing that's a smiley lot journalist
now things look better for the workers
in another part of the factory here
housings for the generating components
of turbines are produced instead of
manufacturing them for offshore
facilities they're concentrating on
land-based wind farms still a large part
of the workforce has had that hours cut
for criminal negligence Minh of
part-time work a few weeks ago was one
of the hardest of my career it was a
very depressing situation and I think
we've solved it well in consultation
with the metal workers union employee
organizations and politicians but still
in human terms it was the most
depressing thing a manager can do
expansion of the power grid from the
coast of southern germany's alpine
regions is progressing slowly at present
that's another reason as a shortage of
orders for offshore wind turbines
there's some I'm definitely on the one
hand there's the sluggish progress of
grid expansion with an enterprise that's
having difficulty providing the means on
the other hand it's politicians if we
want to transition to renewable energy
we can't do it without shore wind power
despite stagnating orders there's no
alternative to the offshore industry in
play muharram a new terminal is planned
for 180 million euros the city's
Planning Department has promoted it and
has resolutely committed to the project
especially because it wants to export
even more there's been the bond whether
we're going to build it because we know
we need the energy transition climate
change affects us here in Brima half
we're raising the dikes we know the
costs and we're convinced we need
renewable energy especially offshore
wind power is that wishful thinking
trade unions see it much as city
planners do the head of negotiations for
the metal workers union is in demand
these days he goes to the affected
companies for example a river one of
power blades rivals here there's even
talk of letting workers go is this just
upkeep and maintenance right now you
must resolve that's about it looks bad
these investments are all quite recent
the factory's been here for three years
and should be pulsing with life several
hundred people should be employed here
so of course it's a dreadful picture
that's really likely its boot and it's
one that won't change in the coming
months just days ago large foundations
for wind turbines were being shipped
from here Kenan against a fire phone
quite a whole bunch of colleagues who
moved here and relocated their lives
because of the work prospects it's
especially bad for that padilla said
latulippe is on their slim new sites are
being developed right next to the
companies who are now employing staff
part-time the projects for them have
long been planned and no one in blame
our half and wants to believe the
expansion of renewable energy will fail
you